So, auf den letzten Drücker
Auf den letzten Drücker, ich hab noch nicht mal alles eingeschaltet
Ich muss gerade mal nebenbei alles anmachen
Moin, zack, Rasch
So, mal gucken was die heute zeigen
Wahrscheinlich Tomb Raider und was auch immer, keine Ahnung
Ich hab keinen Schimmer, was die in der Pileplan haben
Kingdom Hearts, haben sie wahrscheinlich noch
Mal gucken, ob es irgendwas Final Fantasy-mäßiges gibt
Was macht eigentlich das Final Fantasy VII Remake?
Wo sich auf die klorreiche Ideen gekommen sind, das muss man jetzt in Seasons machen
Das war das letzte, was ich davon gelesen hab
Ja, da hoffe ich auch drauf, dass wir uns was von zeigen
Okay, man weiß nichts genaues
Okay, ja, gut, da machst du nichts, ne?
Da machst du nichts
Guck mal, Release Date, Final Fantasy VII Remake
Ob es da schon irgendwas gab in der letzten Zeit, mal
Release angeblich in... Warum eigentlich?
Ich meine, nur weil das Spiel mehrere...
Wie viele CDs hatte das, zwei oder vier?
Weiß das jemand? Wie viele CDs hatte Final Fantasy VII?
Aber ich meine, nur weil das auf mehrere CDs kommt, muss man natürlich mehrere Episoden daraus machen
Weil, ich meine, das Game kam ja auch zusammen
Da waren halt mehrere CDs drin
Was soll diese Episoden so drittes, die sind da teilweise, haben?
Muss man ja verstehen
So, posten wir mal auf
Twitch Wars
Äh
Ich hab Englisch, das ist natürlich auch
Umstellen
Woodface
So, ich bin bereit
Kann losgehen
Achso, ne, ich bin nicht bereit, ich muss nur noch VLC starten
Oh, Screnics, VLC, zack
Das ist ein voll immersives Streamerlebnis heute
Basta
Oh
Ich glaub, das muss man wegmachen
Machen wir VLC an und gucken uns das mal wieder in ordentlicher Auflösung an, in ordentlicher Qualität
Natürlich mit maximalen FPS
Und im Vollbild, dass wir uns den Twitch Chat nicht geben müssen
Wobei, Twitch Chat, jetzt mal ernsthaft, Leute
Twitch Chat ist das, was Twitch gut macht
Ohne Twitch Chat und ohne die Twitch Emotes und alles
Wäre das einfach nur Mixer 0.1 oder so
Ja man, schon weiß ich jetzt nicht, was ich erzähle
Zumal der Mixer erst nach
Naja, was auch immer, ihr wisst, was ich meine, Twitch Chat ist das Beste
Muss
Kommt auch mal wieder ein neues Video, ja
Wann weiß ich noch nicht
Heute gibt es Qualitätseinstellungen
Ok
Wisst ihr, was ich geändert habe seit gestern zu heute an den Settings
Also warum es jetzt Qualitätseinstellungen gibt, wisst ihr, was ich geändert habe
Ethorische Frage
Jetzt habe ich den jetzt eigentlich gepostet auf Twitter
Nichts, genau, der Seilen kills mir, er kann nichts
Die letzten Streams waren alle exakt mit den gleichen Settings
Jetzt müsste es gleich losgehen
Ich mache schon mal die Musik aus
Mal gucken wir mal, dass uns der VLC Player nicht gebated
Wir gucken jetzt mal auf Twitch, ob es losgeht
Und wenn es losgeht schalte ich um auf den VLC, weil Fullscreen und so
Hallo, oh
Wie los
Also es ist Absicht, ich habe keinen Sound gerade
Also jetzt, ok, gut
Bisschen lauter, ne
Ihr müsst mir gleich sagen, wenn ihr anfangen zu labern, wie der Sound ist
Das FPS in meinem Namen
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal zuhören
Square Enix
Nani
Ok, neues Tomb Raider
Ich fand es immer geil, die Leute früher, die immer gesagt haben, Max, das heißt nicht Tomb Raider, das ist das Tomb Raider
Spricht das korrekt aus wie der Tomb Raider, ja?
Nicht Tomb Raider, Tomb Raider
Ich fand es wurscht, habs als Game taugt, was
Irgendwann kaufe ich Tomb Raider auf Amazon
Bisschen leise, oder?
Ich mach
Hier nach lauter
So ist es besser, ne
140% Lautstärke, ja
Cool Story, Bro
O
Die Wachen in den Stealth-Games müssen halt einfach dumm sein, das geht nicht anders.
Sieht keiner.
Oh, eine Flasche, hm, was könnte das sein?
Na, hier ist bestimmt keiner, ich laufe jetzt allein in die Richtung ohne was zu sagen und
BÄM!
In your face!
Stealth-Kill!
Und er merkt es auch nicht, na, das ganze Team wird abgemetzelt hinter ihm, aber Wachen
in Stealth-Games, da ist nichts mit 200 IQ, da ist 45 IQ, wenn es hochkommt.
Also Wachen in Stealth-Games, guckt euch den mal an hier jetzt, dabei hat er schon,
hatte ich gerade Sam Fischer umgebracht, zumindest hat er so ein geiles Sam Fischer
und das hat sich gedrückt!
Ouh!!!
Oh!
Hier in der Busch sieht sich natürlich keiner
Ist klar, wie ein echt...
Oh
Cool ist der mit der Kettensäge oder was knattert da so
Ich hoffe die bringen keine Tiere im Trailer um muss man gleich Peter callen wenn es soweit ist
Weil das geht ja nicht wachen darf es abwetzeln aber irgendwelche Tiere aus dem Dschungel das geht nicht
Es sieht aus wie die letzten zwei oder 360
Das ist die ultimative definitiv Tumbreiter oh oh Peter
Ich finde egal ob bei unschattet bei Tumbreiter bei irgendwelchen filmen dass die so dass sie da immer in
irgendwelche gräber reinsteigen mit uraltem zeug seit tausend von jahren das funktioniert alles wunderbar
Oh habe ich 500 stunden oder so gespielt bis es kein content mehr gab
Mit dem fräscher zusammen
Verkauf mit Wink scream
Unsere Kenntnis und Expertise. Unsere neuen Freunde werden schwer gedrückt, mit einem Fohren, für den Tod nur ein kleiner Unmöglichkeit ist.
Captain Spirit ist hier.
Hallo, mein Name ist Michel Corp. Und mein Name ist Raoul Barbet. Wir sind die zwei kreativen Direktoren von Life is Strange.
Wie ihr wisst, haben wir gerade die tolle Erleichterung von Captain Spirit entdeckt. Es ist eine neue Geschichte im Life is Strange Universum. Und diese volle Erfahrung wird frei downloaden.
Für uns ist Life is Strange nicht ein einziger Teil oder ein Set von Charakteren. Captain Spirit ist unser Weg, die Spieler zu den vielen Geschichten, die wir in diesem erhebenden Universum erzählen wollen.
Captain Spirit ist nicht Life is Strange 2, aber es wird eure ersten Schritte in diesen Welt.
Das Spiel entdeckt viele Geheimnisse und sogar einige Verbindungen mit den neuen Geschichten und Charakteren von Life is Strange 2.
Also macht euch sicher, dass ihr alle eure Zeit verabschiedet.
Wir können euch nicht warten, die Geschichte von Chris zu erleben. Wir hoffen, dass ihr es genießen könnt.
Habt eine tolle Geschichte und von allen Life is Strange Teams und Don't Nod, danke.
Danke, tschüss.
Jetzt muss ich nur eine tolle Kostüme für Captain Spirit machen.
Ich habe bis jetzt noch nichts gesehen, was der Aufhänger von der Story sein soll.
Man sieht halt ein Junge, der Superhelden spielt. Es ist ja nicht so, dass es da ein paar gibt, die sowas machen.
Oh, das Dragon Quest. Sieht zumindest genauso aus wie Dragon Quest.
Das ist schon Dragon Quest.
Oder irgendein Mobile Dragon Quest. Nee, das ist das Neue.
Dragon Quest 85 oder so.
Dragon Quest Royal, genau.
Da warte ich doch drauf.
Dragon Quest Royal. Ich meine, es gab ja schon alle möglichen Dragon Quest Ableger.
Warum?
Weil es so ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen.
Dragon Quest Royal. Ich meine, es gab ja schon alle möglichen Dragon Quest Ableger. Warum nicht auch Dragon Quest Royal?
JRPG halt.
Gruppe aus 16 Jahren muss die Welt retten, aber so ist das halt. So muss das sein.
Das war aber Copper Pride unendet gerade.
Ich bilde mir ein, das ist doch in Japan sogar schon raus.
Oh, Dragon Balls.
Das ist in Japan doch schon raus. Guck mal, Rotkäppchen ist auch am Start.
Die Hapala.
Das werde ich mir auf jeden Fall holen, wenn das was taugt.
Schon lange kein ordentliches JRPG-Make gespielt.
Danke, paar Mädels, weniger Rüstung, gleich mehr Rüstung.
Ich meine, geile Soundtracks haben die schon immer.
Da kann man nichts sagen.
Was könnte das sein?
Hm.
Was ist das?
Ist das irgendein Bohrhemmer oder sowas?
Nee, ich hab keinen Schemmer.
Okay. Was Neues?
Was Neues? Wer hat das gedacht?
Phone für den PC.
Das ist Nier Automata Extreme Definite Dingsbombs Edition.
Ultimate Mega Edition mit Battle Royale.
Die Masterpiece Edition. Was? Become as Gods Edition?
Das geht Schlag auf Schlagpass, Querenix.
Ist das Final Fantasy Tactics oder sowas?
Sowas ähnliches, hä?
Was für die Switch?
Langweiliges Game.
Was ist das?
Fischphysik.
Ich finde die Reihe so langweilig.
Das ist so ein typisches...
Das ist so ein typisches Game, da spielst du zwei Stunden, machst ein bisschen Zeug kaputt und dann spielst du es nie wieder.
Ich meine, was einfallen lassen sie sich ja schon.
Story.
Ich glaube in Story hat das noch nie geklänzt.
Hübsch ist es.
Zumindest kommt es auf allen Plattformen, das ist doch schon mal was.
Mirrors Edge 25.
Wobei nein, falscher, falscher Hersteller.
Was ist das denn?
Und jetzt in Game Grafik, was überhaupt nicht auffällt, der Übergang.
Warum hat man das nicht gleich in Game gezeigt?
Jetzt ist es wieder, hä?
Ich meine, als hätte man das jetzt nicht gesehen.
Ich weiß nicht.
Warum musste das jetzt in echt sein und das andere in Game?
Jetzt kommt Kingdom Hearts.
Das ist genau das gleiche, haben sie gestern ja schon gezeigt, das ist exakt der gleiche Trailer.
Oder?
Doch, ist es.
Gibt es irgendjemand, der die Kingdom Hearts Story checkt?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da abgeht.
Ich habe nur das erste gespielt auf der PS2.
Ja, Flamius, beste Erklärung, das ist ein Typ, der schlägt alle mit dem Schlüssel.
Ach komm!
Der Voice Actor.
Also ich errate, ich versuche mal die Story zu erraten.
Die Welt ist von bösen Mächten bedroht und der Oberbösewicht möchte der Herrscher über das komplette Universum oder sonst was werden.
Und die Helden müssen ihm werden.
Also die Welt, das Universum, alles.
Das wäre nämlich was ganz Innovatives, das hat es nur noch nie gegeben.
Alter, der Voice Actor.
Ich glaube, die Story, die von Kingdom Hearts, es gibt keinen, der die checkt.
Das ist so eine der wirksten Geschichten, die es überhaupt gibt.
Ja, es ist fertig.
Es ist fertig, oder?
Es sieht aus wie der Outro-Trailer.
Naja, im Prinzip, warum nicht?
Spiele gezeigt, Gutes.
So könnte es überall sein.
Zwei Stunden, wie genial sie sind, Gelaber muss doch nicht sein.
Einfach, einfach Spielezeiten gut ist.
So, was ist denn die nächste?
Mal gucken wann, ich glaube die ist aber zu spät für mich.
Ich glaube die PC gerne ist...
Die hatten da was, ja.
Also, gut.
Ja, Termine.
So, als nächstes haben wir dann, oh nee, 22 Uhr.
Ich muss morgen 5.45 Uhr aufstehen, das ist zu spät.
Kann ich das mal zu ordentlich in die Uhrzeiten machen?
Also, zufällig in Fantasy 7 kein Wort, was mich ein bisschen verwirrt.
Weil das haben die ja schon auch wieder vor, keine Ahnung, 2, 3 Jahren oder so angekündigt.
Und irgendwann haben sie gesagt, das kommt jetzt in Episoden.
Oder hat man nichts davon gehört?
So, ich muss mal kurz den Chat gucken.
Also, wie gesagt, ich habe hier nichts beantwortet zwischendurch.
Weil ich nicht zu sehr reinlabern wollte.
Ich gucke mal, ob es da irgendwas Interessantes gibt.
Was arbeitest du, dass du so früh aufstehen musst? Ich stehe freiwillig so früh auf.
Da kannst du nicht früher wieder heimgehen.
Früher kommen, früher gehen, so ist das.
Big Brain.
Kann man deinen Stream nachher als Video sehen?
Ja klar, das ist alles bei Twitch.
Oder alternativ gehst du auf die Archivseite von Silbaro.
Da sind alle Streams seit, soll er selbst schreiben?
Ich weiß nicht seit wann.
Was ist eigentlich deine aktuelle Meinung zu Switch?
Ich denke immer noch, das Konzept ist gut.
Die Hardware ist gut.
Also schnell genug, reicht.
Keine Schmerzen mit.
Das Problem ist, dass es kaum Games gibt, die was für mich sind.
Und dass der Online-Modus sowas von rückständig ist, das muss man gar nicht erwähnen.
Mal gucken, was Nintendo da ankündigt morgen.
Hast du nie Automata gespielt? Nope.
Leider kann ich nicht weiter zurückscrollen.
Wir können jetzt mal kurz gucken, was haben denn die anderen angekündigt?
Also was haben wir verpasst?
Wir haben die Volver verpasst und wir haben Bethesda verpasst.
Gucken wir doch mal.
Ich muss mal Stäubung T anbinden.
Summary. Gucken wir mal was da war.
Recap. All Trailers.
Ja das ist gut.
Wollen wir uns das noch angucken?
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob es auf YouTube einen Bethesda Summary oder sowas gibt?
Wie spricht man die eigentlich richtig aus?
Bethesda, Bethesda, Bethesda.
Also ich bin für Bethesda.
Bethesda Summary.
Warte mal, wir hatten doch eben was mit All Trailers, das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
All Trailers, was auch immer das für ein Block ist.
Gbait, Clickbait, Clickbait.
Okay, aber das ist dann eine ganz gute Auflistung.
Okay, schauen wir mal aus.
Das erste, was wir gezeigt haben, war anscheinend Rage 2.
Rage 1 war ja unglaublich langweilig.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen, YouTube?
Alter.
Okay, Rage 2 Trailer.
Da gibt es bestimmt welche ohne.
So viel zu Alltagsfreige auf YouTube.
Sag mal, die Grafik ist nicht gut? Pixel nicht?
Rage 1 war übelst langweilig.
Schreien, richtig.
Hello E3, and welcome to the world of Rage 2.
Ja, rumgefahren ist man Rage 1 auch viel.
Und ich fand das Fahren in Rage 1 auch übelst langweilig.
Ich fand ganzes Rage 1 übelst langweilig.
Rage 2, ja.
Okay, es blättert, deswegen war das ab 18.
So dangerous sind die jetzt aber nicht, oder?
Das ist auch Last Man Standing, wie es aussieht.
Okay, Ballerballerballer, Rennen, Ballerballerballer.
Shotguns, Linen, in die Eier schießen, Ballerballer.
Also quasi Rage 1.
Bloß vielleicht ohne die langweiligen Parts zwischendurch.
Das erinnert mich jetzt fast schon ein bisschen an Doom.
Okay.
Danke für die 5 Euro, Mr.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, Mr.
Mr.
Harobo 1.
Ich habe keine Donation vergessen.
Sie betet mich nicht.
Also ein bisschen erinnert es mich schon an Doom, oder?
Das ist natürlich sehr, das ist auch sehr klapper.
Du hast einen Boss, der nur Mehle kann.
Du rennst hin.
Das ist ja Big Brain.
Das könnte was werden.
Also es könnte ernsthaft was werden.
Es kommt halt drauf an, ob die langweiligen Parts dazwischen nicht wieder komplette Spaß
töten.
So, was haben sie noch gezeigt?
Elder Scrolls, das ist ein Kartenspiel.
Okay, Hearthstone, Mobile mit Controller, bloß dass es nicht Hearthstone ist.
Naja, auf der Switch immerhin.
Gut, die wollen halt auch, die wollen halt auch ein Hearthstone Klon haben.
Elder Scrolls Online Trailer, okay das ist bestimmt für eine neue Expansion.
So, das finde ich super, sich das im Nachhinein anzugucken.
Da fällt das ganze Gelaber zwischendurch weg.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr keinen, dass sie so committed sind und dass sie die besten Fans haben und
dass sie die Plattform immer vorantreiben werden bis ans Ende aller Tage und nur auf
ne, aber ne, einfach Trailer und Gutes.
Was gestern live auf, live beim Auftritt bei Bethesda war ultra cringe.
Das wenn es ultra cringe war, müssen wir uns das angucken.
Ich habe damals die Beta gespielt, also als Elder Scrolls Online neu war und ich, das
war so, ich weiß nicht, es hat mich so wenig beeindruckt, dass ich gar nicht mehr weiß,
was mir nicht gefallen hat.
Es hat mir zumindest so wenig gefallen, dass ich gar nicht dran gedacht habe mir die Vollversion
zu holen, aber irgendwann muss man auch mal rein cashen.
Man muss ja auch Kohle verdienen, mit MMOs kann man, vor allem mit Abo Modell, ist das
noch Abo?
Ist das noch Sub oder ist das free to play?
Weiß das jemand von euch, free to play oder Abo?
Am Anfang war es nämlich glaube ich Abo, mittlerweile ist es bestimmt free to play.
Nice Musik.
Ok, wem?
Okay, wem, wer da spielt? Spielt das jemand von euch?
Doom Eternal. Aha. Spielt das jemand von euch?
Also nicht Doom Eternal. Er lasst wohl anscheinend. Was denn das?
Next. Doom Eternal.
Ey, die Beta hab ich auch gespielt.
Der PvP war einfach Crap beim letzten Doom.
Da hatten sie ja so eine Marketing-Kampagne am Laufen, wo sie sich wieder ein paar bekannte Influencer geholt haben für das Game.
Die das Game dann loben mussten. Was sagen wir, nicht loben mussten, aber auch nicht unbedingt so viel schlechtes, tun wir sagen.
Und trotzdem war der Multiplayer einfach scheiße.
Okay, warum nicht? Der letzte Teil war gut. Nehmen wir. Quake Champions, jawoll.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was da draus wird. Also das ist ja schon spielbar.
Moment, ein bisschen leise, ha? Und es wird bestimmt noch lauter. Ne.
Es gibt ja auch viele Quake-Pros, die wieder Quake Champions spielen jetzt. Wenn man mal auf Twitch guckt.
Ja, kennt man, das gibt es ja schon. Also jeder, der das Spiel will, kann es schon spielen, muss man nicht drauf warten.
Und ich hatte am Anfang ja die Bedenken, als sie das allererste gezeigt haben von dem Game, dass es viel zu sehr in Richtung MOBA bzw. Overwatch abklatscht geht, aber ist es gar nicht.
Also für alle, die Quake mochten, werden das wahrscheinlich auch mögen.
Also wem Quake gefällt, für den ist das mit Sicherheit was.
Oh, ein neues Prey. Ach ne DLC, okay. Debated. Eigentlich fast schon Scamast.
Okay. Prey Mooncrash Trailer. Gucken wir uns halt den Trailer nicht beim offiziellen Channel an. So. Gucken wir uns halt den Trailer bei, weiß ich, da an.
Wir sind zu laut.
Habe ich nicht gespielt? Es soll gut gewesen sein. Hat aber mit dem Teil davor überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Quake war das nicht die eine Tournamentkopie. Nee, eher umgedreht.
Außerdem haben die Spiele nicht so viel miteinander gemein gehabt.
Okay.
Ich finde, dass die Musik da nicht dazu passt.
Das steht auch noch auf meiner Liste.
Ich habe es nicht gespielt.
Ich weiß nicht warum, also das hat ja überall auch gute Bewertungen gekriegt.
Ach, das ist... Was ist denn das? Ich meine ernsthaft? Der macht hinter offiziellen Trailer... Macht das sein bitte? Subscriben. ETF.
Das ist ja auch eine wahnsinnige Leistung den offiziellen Trailer hochzuladen bei sich.
Die wollen es aber wissen, oder? Was bei Patasta allerdings irgendwo klappt ist, die Spiele taugen meistens was, obwohl es ein Aufguss ist.
Äh. Hä? Ach, habe ich verklickt. Oh, komm mal, ey. Young Blood.
Announcement Trailer. Ja. Wie die mich debaten? Moment, wir wollen von Anfang an gucken.
Oh, oh. Bent. Bent. Das hat keiner gesehen. Bent. Oh ne. Bent.
Wolfenschein Grille Edition.
Skyrim Very Special Edition. Okay, das ist bestimmt ein Gag, ne? Weil ich mein, Skyrim gibt es ja schon in allen erdenklichen Varianten.
The Elder Scrolls speak of the past and the future. Now Skyrim looks to the future, to its ultimate version.
PC.
Das ist doch echt gut geworden.
Skyrim Alexa Edition.
Yes, right, yes, of course, you're the greatest. Thank you so much.
Introducing Skyrim Very Special Edition. Also, coming soon to Etch A Sketch. Motorola Pages.
Die anderen müssten das auch alles vielmehr mit Humor nehmen, ne?
Anstatt dass sich Phil Spencer hinstellt und quasi viermal bei Microsoft das Gleiche erzählt, da hat er wirklich bei jedem Mal, wo er auf der Bühne gestanden hat, gestern exakt den gleichen Krempel erzählt.
Sollen sie lieber sowas produzieren, das ist doch witzig. So, Fallout 69.
Das kennen wir noch, das kennen wir schon von Microsoft.
So.
Ja, das ist der gleiche Trailer, den kennen wir schon.
Fucking Trees.
Kona.
Es wird bestimmt kein grottisches Game. Ob es richtig gut wird, muss ich zeigen. Letztes Mal ist es nicht so mein Fall, aber es wird bestimmt nicht grottenschlecht.
Das sind nicht nur Gebäude, sondern Herz und Geist. Und letztendlich muss die USA selbst gerebildet werden.
Das muss das sein.
Was haben wir noch?
Was ist das?
Komm, Bra. Muss das sein?
Das Kampfsystem sieht ultra langweilig aus.
Das Kampfsystem sah so statisch aus, so langweilig.
Oh, man kann hochkant machen, wer hätte das gedacht?
Was ist das? FOF, FOF 24 oder was? Was ist das für ein FOF jetzt? Geht das überhaupt noch?
FOF 5.
Das sagt halt gar nichts aus, wenn die einfach da irgendwas aufgezeichnet haben, um zu zeigen, ob das wirklich so geil aussieht, ob das nicht so gut spielt. Das sagen ja alle. Und das Kampfsystem sieht einfach schlecht aus.
Einfach total hakelig und langweilig. Mobile halt. Mobile Crap. Instant Refund. Wobei, warum Refund? Ich kaufe es mir gar nicht.
Das ist da, wo man Microtransactions kaufen kann.
Und Ingamewährung. Und Lootboxen. Und Skins. Und Pets.
So Animal Crossing, oder?
Naja, Mobile halt. Ja, gut, Next. Starfield. Sagt mir gar nichts.
Stehe fest.
Okay, das war absolut nichts sagen, auch kann ich nicht sagen, das war absolut nichts sagen.
Also wirklich komplett nichts sagen.
What? What? Ernsthaft?
Mobile!
Okay, das ist auch sehr nichts sagen, aber ich glaube alle Elder Scrolls Fans werden sich
freuen, dass es jetzt offiziell ist.
Jetzt ja gut mit den Battle Royale Witzen, irgendwann lache ich auch nicht mehr drüber.
So, was haben wir noch verpasst gestern?
Alter, ich muss was anbinden.
So, was haben wir noch verpasst?
Was ist jetzt los?
Warum läuft da was?
PC Games!
Come on bro, wo ist hier was an?
Stay tuned, für was denn?
Für was sollen wir stay tuned bleiben?
Die Wolver haben wir noch verpasst, gab es da was interessantes?
Ja, gucken wir nochmal.
Summary, gucken wir mal was die gebracht haben, Press Conference Recap, also was haben die
gezeigt?
War es das?
Muss man sich da von irgendwas angucken?
Achso, das war wieder so eine Debate-Presse-Konferenz, um die anderen ein bisschen zu verarschen.
Die Wolver E3 2018, Full Press Conference, wollen wir es uns noch geben Leute, 15 Minuten?
Dann haben wir im Prinzip alles, was heute Nacht gelaufen ist, in einer halben Stunde
aufgeholt.
Microsoft haben wir geguckt, dann sind wir wieder up to date, Square Enix haben wir geguckt,
Ubisoft.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich Ubisoft mache heute, eigentlich ist es zu spät, eigentlich ist
es zu spät, das ist aber nicht der Anfang, Moment, nicht live-reaction.
Gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal auf Twitch irgendwo, Moment, nein, äh, ne, ne, das ist
was anderes, ja gut, dann gucken wir uns jetzt halt hier irgendwas von an, ich hätte halt
gerne was von, ok, das ist anscheinend der Anfang, was, das lief auf dem Twitch-Channel,
dem da, ich hab's nicht gesehen jetzt, guck mal, past broadcast, ne, ne, irgendwie nicht,
na gut, dann gucken wir jetzt das hier, ach, auf dem richtigen Twitch-Channel, ja, was
haben die denn für einen, was haben die denn für einen?
Keine Ahnung.
hier gehts los
zu leise
okay das geht nicht lang 15 minuten nur
und irgend einer meinte doch am anfang bei princess da was übels cringe für übels cringe
bin ich immer zu haben das muss man danach auch noch kurz angucken
ja schau dir das an das ist alles was du tötest
tötest es und weißt du was so sind wir so sind wir viele veränderungen seit dem letzten
time wir hier lots of changes lots of progress synergies aligned efficiencies modulated new
management gut die waren deswegen sind wir ganz lustig und we couldn't have done any of that
without all of you we stepped it up you guys stepped it all the way up we've examined the industry
and our place in it we worked hard to widen our excellence perimeter engender fiscal aptitude
and re-intermediate intuitive strategies to promote cutting edge principle centered future
ich war die verarschen das ganze business gelabert ja schon ganz gut
super excited
visitors
i read on the internet this one time that some of you had some proper shit to say about
in unserer Pressekonferenz letztes Jahr.
Dass es nicht professionell war.
Dass es nicht wie eine echte Videogameskonferenz gefühlt hat,
von einem echten Videogames-Publisher,
der echte Videogames publiziert.
Dass es alles ein Kind von Witz war.
Witz.
Sie waren super falsch.
Und um es zu zeigen,
haben wir dieses Jahrs Jiminy-Finger
alles, was Sie erwarten würden,
von einer Produktion dieser Größe.
Dieses Jahr haben wir überflüssige Grafiken,
die Sie von unbekannten Dialogern beinhalten.
Gast-Appearanzen von Charaktere,
die Sie erkennen können,
und die Sie mit einer verletzten Familiarität zeigen,
weil Sie sie in Videos auf der Internet gesehen haben.
Und die Gast-Appearanzen werden eine erhebliche Nostalgia-Response
aufbauen.
Und das ist 2018. Und das ist, wie das Marketing jetzt ist.
Wir haben auch ein neues Spiel,
wie Sie sagen, ein neues Spiel auf dem Schaum.
Obwohl es klar ist,
dass es eine vorgeschlossene Sequenz ist,
mit vernünftigen Planungen,
und vorgeschlossenen Monaten voran.
Aber was stand am meisten aus?
Was wirklich in der flamen Trash-Pile
in der unendenden Ozeane unbekanter Feedback
von letztes Jahrs Pressekonferenz stand,
war, dass Sie, Simpletons,
ja, Sie,
Sie stinkenden Minions,
denken, dass wir nicht genug neue Spiele
und Vorstellungen,
oder was auch immer noch,
haben Sie Ihren dummen kleinen Leben
ein bisschen weniger unbekanter.
In dem einen Moment auf der Internet,
in dem einen Moment.
Und das,
das hat uns richtig in den Fällen getroffen.
Also dieses Jahr
bringen wir Ihnen
diese neuen Spiele,
diese ersten Aufnahmen,
diese Vorstellungen
für Projekte,
die Sie niemals gedacht haben, möglich zu sein.
Das erste ist von Gamepires.
Es ist das Supermax Survival Sim Scum.
Sie können es kaufen.
Es wird uns große Nummern machen.
Und das ist wirklich so heiß.
Aber ich weiß es nicht,
weil ich dieses Garbage nicht spiele.
Klappe den Garbage!
Scum-Season 2 steigt auf
mit den tec-1s
auf dem Display.
Mit über 3x so vielen Drohnen
werden die Zuschauer
die intimsten Momente des Konterstens genießen.
Neue Waffen und Gewehr
erhöhen die Aktien.
Aber es ist der Trademark Paranoia,
der die Savagerie zu neuen Höhen fährt.
Das macht Scum
eine Freude für die ganze Familie.
Keine Sorge,
die tec-1-Sicherheit
ist auf dem Weg,
um Konterstens zu machen.
Oh mein Gott.
Und natürlich.
Der Lieblingsfavorite,
Mr. Smiles,
ist wieder zurück
für Regeln.
Was?
Die Fremde ist ermordet.
Scum.
Willkommen zu der nächsten Ära
im Supermax Survival.
What?
Da weiß man jetzt gar nicht,
ob man debatet wird oder nicht.
All Contestant Corpses will be reused in Scum
for government regulations.
Scum Game.
Well,
that looks like a hell of a lot of fun
for the kids, am I right?
Go to scumgame.com
for more information
or don't,
I get paid either way.
Up next,
we have...
Moment, Leute.
Moment.
Die scheinen das ernst zu meinen.
Okay, die meinen das ernst.
Das ist kein...
Das war kein Debate.
Das gibt's wirklich.
Ob's natürlich nicht doch
letztendlich irgendwie ein Gag ist,
keine Ahnung.
Aber ich muss ja auch Geld verdienen.
Let's go!
Endlich!
Zeigen sie die richtigen.
Die guckt schon so ein bisschen so,
als springen sie dich gleich an.
Well, endlich!
Produkt Lüt box
Was Endlös
So fucking secure, not even the owners know its actual value
Totally unregulated and absent of all civil
governmental
international personal or
institutional liability
Lüt box coin aims to become the global standard in meaningless wealth acquisition and questionable financial stability
Lüt box coin cannot be mined cannot be opened cannot be blockchained cannot be walleted or
crypto
And what can you do with it? Nothing!
This is really well done this time again!
One of our hastily trained economists will create and send you an actual physical Lüt box coin just like the one I'm holding right here in my motherfucking hand. What is it worth? I don't know. What can you buy with it? Probably nothing. Does the US government consider it a form of gambling? Fuck! If I care! Lüt box coin is available now on the Devolver Digi-
Moment!
Also die nehmen ihr Zeug wenigstens ernst
Geh du guck du kommst halt mal den im Shop raus. Übrigens wo wir gerade bei Coins sind, ne? Letztens habe ich bei Amazon was gesehen
Was ist denn? Da hat irgendwie einer das System nicht verstanden, glaube ich. Ist er sich genau das Gegenteil von dem, wie es gedacht ist? Ich meine zumal dieses Ding mit Bitcoins nichts zu tun. The fuck? Warum? Wo ist der Sinn? Man weiß es nicht. Kommen wir weiter.
Don't believe me? Well go fire up a browser and check it out.
Up next, we have a game that some of you may have seen on the socials via hilariously violent gifs from developer DeadToast, pronounce it jits.
xD
Ich bin noch nie besonders fasziniert von Gewalt, aber das sind schlechte Menschen.
Schlechte Menschen, die gehalten werden müssen.
Also, lass uns verrückt werden.
Lass uns seltsam werden.
Lass uns...
...nachher...
..nachher...
....nachher...
...nachher...
Happy Wheels 3
Jake's an Asshole